- Des fois, il faut tourner
puis... non, ça serait bien s'il
était visible tout de suite.
- Un nouvel étiquetage arrivera
comme celui-ci, sur le devant
des emballages alimentaires
riches en gras saturés, en sucre
tableau des valeurs nutritives.
JEAN-YVES DUCLOS, ministre
fédéral de la Santé
nutritionnel sur le devant
des emballages est distinctif,
très visible et facile à
identifiaux consaux consaux cont
faire de bons choix.
de gras, de sucre ou de sodium
peut contribuer au développement
de maladies chroniques.
Le gouvernement estime que
rapide de reconnaître
ons plus saines.
Et les consommateurs, justement,
y sont favorables.
de cholestérol, de sucre, et...
de gras. Donc, avec ça, je vais
être capable d'étalonner ou...
j'ingère.
- C'est vrai que cas
mal plus pratique d'avoir ça
en avant. Puis des fois, que çat
certains choix, des fois
d'aliments qu'on fait parce
ou quoi que ce soit, on ne s
donne pas toujours la peine
en arrière.
CAROL-ANN ROBERT, nutritionniste
diététiste, ÉquipeNutrition
- Tout ce qui est ons,
mets préparés, souvent, quand
je vois des clients ens ens ensn
consultation, c'est ça qui porte
le plus à confusion. Qu'est-ce
qui est mais il y a
de belles différences au niveau
des valeurs nutriturs nutriturs,
ça va être vraiment plus facile
de faire des choix éclairés pour
ça.
- Un tel symbole sera exigé sur
la plupart, mais pas la totalité
des proddes proddes proddes pro.
Parmi les exemptions, on compte
les fruits et légumes, le lait,
les oeufs, les viandes et
volailles hachées crues.
trie alimentaire a
jusqu'au 1er janvier 2026 pour
s'ajuster. Certaines compagnies
pourraient toutefois faire
les modifications
Ici, Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Mon